[Music]
well may the fourth be with couples who
are looking to
tie the knot to remember this day
there's a local wedding chapel offering
star wars themed weddings alex oh yeah
people
are already taking advantage fans have
another reason to celebrate this holiday
hector mega live from the little vegas
chapel with a look
hey hector what's going on
hey there well this day has evolved to
include
weddings we're about to witness one
right now this is a mock wedding for
demonstration purposes to kind of
illustrate what they have going on here
and so this is the first time they do
this and it's all for the true
star wars fans and joining us live we
have chrissy
to talk to us about what's going on hi
so we are witnessing a star wars famed
wedding that we threw together for star
wars day today
the package is by friday night before
attacks and includes all this fun stuff
they're about to see here
thank you we'll come back to you but we
want to listen just a little bit to
the lines because they include lines
from the movie so let's go ahead and
listen in
firstly welcome young panawans to the
new chapter
the two of you will bring into your
lives
han do you take mando to be your
mandalorian
do you take han to be your jedi
companion for life
we'll do some special vows a mandalorian
and a jedi getting
married this morning at six o'clock in
the morning at six o'clock in the
morning yes so these guys are huge star
wars fans
so we wanted to throw something special
for those guys to enjoy
their time here in vegas so that's what
the star wars package is for
you know some people look forward to
christmas all year long
others look forward to star wars day
today
exactly there's so there's something for
everyone literally so that's what we're
here for we want to create a package for
those people that love
star wars and the entire movie sega so
you know there's something for everyone
here and congratulations
there they go walking off into the
horizon galaxy far far away
so what reaction have you gotten from
people so far
as they do the bookings for reactions so
you know
so we're known for affordable weddings
here in vegas so we're known for
stress-free weddings that's what we want
to
provide for our couples we heard a lot
of fun reactions about the star wars
wedding some bookings for it
so you know we're looking forward to
continuing the tourism here in las vegas
and keeping up from what we
increasingly so this is not your typical
wedding obviously so you're obviously
not going to have your typical bouquet
no that's not our worst day but we do
have plenty of arrangements for our
couples to enjoy
fresh soap roses anything they want
all right thank you very much so they're
signing off and
it's an exciting day for them and this
is just one example of
the weddings are offering here bianca i
have this for you i understand you were
trying to
catch a bouquet a few weeks ago but i
think i have one here just ready for you
right now
reporting live from the galaxy far far
away
somewhere in downtown las vegas hector
mekia 8 news now
and it lights up so you're not going to
miss it this time
exactly exactly hector's always looking
out i'm ready and it matches
see it's blue i got on blue hector
the stars are aligning just there in the
galaxy
don't miss either because that's a
lightsaber and that can hurt yes
well you'll know how serious those folks
are if they can get a lightsaber that
will actually cut the wedding cake